si vous voulez j'ai été saisi de
plusieurs dossiers depuis le premier
confinement et des faits très graves
notamment avec le dossier de madame
schwarz mais on va écouter son
témoignage est que le livre est sorti il
ya eu un mouvement de libération de la
parole les gens m'ont dit non mais c'est
pas possible je m'en rends compte là on
ne peut plus rien faire il faut agir
donc ça agit comme un déclencheur si
vous voulez et les actes dénoncés sont
très graves on parle de gens qu'on ne
nourrit pas qu on ne lave pas des gens
qu'on enferme dans leur chambre on parle
vraiment d'alimentation il y a des gens
qu'on prive même dos quand il sonne
personne ne vient pendant des heures
donc oui ce sont des faits d'une extrême
gravité pour représenter combien de
familles de victimes alors pour
l'instant je vous avoue ma boite mail
explose mais réseaux sociaux également
donc je l'a par exemple entre ce matin
et là j'ai reçu 400 mails non je dirais
plusieurs dizaines pour ce que j'ai pu
ouvrir mais il ya également des mails ou
ce sont des salariés qui me disent nous
on gagné par exemple le smic on avait
une famille à nourrir on ne pouvait pas
quitter cet emploi on était obligé
finalement un peu d' obéir mais là on
est prêt à témoigner alors on est avec
isabelle choix refus de aux clientes un
raid a fait des victimes vous êtes la
fille de monique soir qu'ils étaient
dans un ehpad du groupe hors pair
pendant presque cinq mois du mas de mars
2020 au 30 juin au 30 juillet 2020
pendant ce séjour vous remarquez que
votre maman est victime de maltraitance
est ce qu'elle était en bonne santé
avant d'intégrer les pattes d'autres
moments maman était en bonne santé elle
avait de légers troubles cognitifs
garder petite perte de mémoire et un
tout début d'alzheimer mais vraiment
tout début et elle et elle marche elle
est autonome elle n'était pas un
continent tels étaient en bonne santé
voilà pourquoi elle avait intégré de cet
établissement alors passe comme elle a
ses petits troubles cognitifs on avait
peur de la laisser ça là la maison
d'accord allez trouver une structure
avec du personnel à domicile et on
m'avait conseillé je n'avais pas trouvé
le personnel à domicile tout de suite
parce qu'il fallait des gens de
confiance si on m'avait dit écoute
pendant cette petite phrase tu peux la
mettre puisqu'elle s'était cassé le col
du fémur et elle avait été en maison de
rééducation une maison de soins de suite
et c'est la maison de soins de soins de
suite qui m'avait dit mais tu es là
derrière pendant quelques mois le temps
que vous mettiez en place toute
l'infrastructure vous payé combien pour
moi par mois donc il pas visière
milliers d'euros mais beaucoup ont
effectué aux alentours de six mois
message m voici les noms
d'oncles à bon marché pas au co2 alors
ça a démarré très rapidement j'ai
commencé à me rendre compte que maman
perdait un petit peu sa motivation par
n'est pas être est un peu frustré et
quelques semaines après son entrée
c'était le début de confinement d'accord
ça a été un problème on pouvait pas
l'avoir normalement on devait
communiquer en fait stein soi disant que
le personnel tous les jours nous offrait
le temps de parole de deux minutes ou 3
minutes avec nos parents mais c'était
plutôt une fois par semaine et on me
téléphone un jour et on me dit votre
mère est tombée elle a beaucoup saigné
s'attacher la moquette
oui ça en fait des messages de lâcher la
moquette voilà la moquette elle est dans
sa énormément seigner génie mais comment
ça elle est tombée quand mayer jeudi
mais vous me l'aviez pas dit et je lui
dis vous avez fait des points de suture
vous avez fait des radios on m'a répondu
on n'a pas fait de points de suture
parce qu'on est arrivé ça saigne et plus
déjà mais il y avait beaucoup de sang
j'ai dit mais vous avez fait une radio
voir s'il n'y a pas un hématome s'il n'y
a pas un trauma ah ben non première
chose moment éristique cinq mois il ya
eu quatre accidents ensuite lors du
confinement on n'avait pas le droit de
la voir non se voyait derrière une glace
moi j'étais dehors et derrière monde las
on avait chacun un masque même mère
était très coquette comme vous avez pu
voir c'était une dame coquette avec un
beau sourire ou bah oui un telle mère
telle fille c est donc l baisse son
masque et elle pleure et là je vois que
ses dents ont été cassées
donc elle avait des trous mais il y
avait plus de dents moment avec des
facettes et il y avait plus d'un aurait
défiguré qui
est là elle pleure et là je me dis j'ai
demandé à ce qu'on fout de ses yeux
parce que de la voir comme ça d'un sur
dur et voilà en un mois en à moi donc je
peux pas moi je suis moi même chirurgien
dentiste non même si je ne peux pas ici
c'est insupportable de voir ça c'est
insupportable je peux pas expliquer ça
je ne peux l'expliquer que de palau
voyez ça volutes vous lui dites pas
oublié mais qu'est-ce qui se passe hélas
elle pleure et à l'arrivée pas
s'exprimer à mehdi je suis moche comme
ça je suis machin je suis machin je peux
pas me regarder dans la glace une image
mais tout ça derrière une glace donc moi
je vais je vais porter plainte je
discute alors vous avez une main quand
j'ai fait notre main courante non mais
enfin quand j je portais plainte je vais
me plaindre
auprès des dirigeants et des soignants
je dis que c'est inadmissible je demande
d explication aucune explication j'exige
d'avoir accès à sa chambre pour pouvoir
me faire des soins pour pas la laisser
comme ça donc j'ai accès à la chambre et
là je vois que sa bouche était dans un
état déplorable
je prends des empreintes jumain
provisoire et après je demande à la
faire sortir pour la soigner au cas
d'option et lorsque j'ai demandé à la
faire sortir j'ai vu que ma mère n'avait
plus du tout les mêmes réflexes déjà
qu'elle marchait beaucoup moins bien et
qu'elle était hagard qu'elle était
perdue et qu'elle avait son image qui
était complètement détériorés c'est
important pour les personnes âgées de
rester joli village d'avoir pu saler
manach là on la voyait l'été
et pas maquillée ni loyer c'est une
belle femme 88 ans sur ses balles toi
donc je l'emmène au cabinet je lui
procure des soins et je préviens les
pattes que je la ramène vers 18 heures
avant le repas on arrive en voiture et
là il ya personne pour recevoir ma mère
pas de chaise rien j'étais avec une amie
qui peut même la tester on trouve une
chaise roulante sur laquelle n'y avait
même pas les repose pieds dont moi
j'étais accroupi à 4 pas à lui tenir les
pieds pour pas que ses pieds traîne le
sol pour la monter dans sa chambre et la
personne nous accueille ça c'était le
deuxième incident troisième incident et
ma mère parlait de moi ce n'est pas
exactement comment il s'était cassé les
dents ou d'aller essayer de savoir on
m'a pas dit moi je pense que c'est un
manque d'hygiène ils n'ont pas dû lui
laver les dents ils ont dû lui donner
des choses très sucrée elle devait pas
beaucoup boire parce qu'elle avait l'air
déshydraté également je précisais je
demandais à ce qu'on met de l'eau est là
elle devait pas beaucoup voir donc du
coup il y avait une fermentation plus
importante dans la cavité buccale et ça
fait une carie décarie flambante et elle
a dû croquer quelque chose ça casse et
elle n'a pas pu me dire elle avait mal
salut blessés l'un d'ailleurs des joues
et ils n'ont rien fait ils ne m'en avait
pas parlé c'est honteux troisième
incident en début juillet on m'appelle
un dimanche vers 12h45 et on me dit
votre maman est tombé jeudi allaient
tomber qu'est ce qui s'est passé elle
est tombée quand mondiale est tombée
hier il ya peut-être une suspicion de
fracture j'ai une suspicion de fracture
j'arrive en plus j'avais précisé j'avais
stipulé lorsque je les ai fait cette
admission là j'étais pétrifiée parce que
pour moi on met pas les parents dans des
dans des maisons on les garde à la
maison j'ai toujours promis qu en garde
à la maison je faisais tout pour la
garder à la maison et donc je n'y mets à
lui tombé quand elle est tombée hier
julie elle est tombée hier samedi ils
vont me prévenez dimanche à 12h45 d'une
suspicion de fracture et on dit oui on
l'a couchée l'avait mal les pays ce
matin ben mal encore mal j'arrive je
vois ma mère qui était habillé donc elle
n'avait pas sa tenue du coucher c'est à
dire elle n'était pas en pyjama donc ils
avaient déjà mobilisé il avait mobilisé
l'épaule le bras pour la mettre en
pyjama il l'avait remobiliser pour la
rhabiller hélas le
l'infirmier me dit oui on pense qu'à une
suspicion de fracture à l'épaule gym on
va aller à l'hôpital donc on part elle
était juste à l'ehpad à côté à boulogne
le corbusier donc on part en ambulance à
l'hôpital la l'hôpital en pleine période
de vide 6h ma mère toute seule dans les
couloirs et moi dehors j'avais pas loin
d'être à côté l'enfer est au bout de six
heures je la retrouve ma fille m'avait
rejoint elle était complètement prostrée
elle savait pas ce qui s'était passé
elle était dans un couloir sur un
brancard toute seule et elle avait sa
main avec un dujarrier c'est une attelle
de contention qui laisse la main comme
ça et elle savait pas où elle était et
elle parlait plus la seule chose qui le
disait ma monte ma montre c'est tout
parce que c'était une attache à cette
montre on repart en a ri et je demande à
l'hôpital s'ils pouvaient lagarde est
hospitalisé il me dit non en pleine
période de vie d'une dame âgée il vaut
mieux car en tournant les pages je
retourne à l'ehpad l'été huit heures du
soir maman était absolument pannetier et
donc je demande à rester à passer la
nuit à coups tutelle m'ont dit non je
savais moi je peux m'asseoir par terre
je lui donne la main ce que je veux
c'est la main elle est perdue elle
fleure al amal ont dit non je dis ok
mais tu es des barrières sur le lumie
pour pas qu'elle tombe parce qu'elle
peut rechuter ont dit non elle avait
chuté comment vous on ne sait jamais
décès jamais un sésame alors quoi
préalablement le chutait jamais jamais
dès la chute deux fois on ne sait pas
comment on sait pas comment et à chaque
fois c'est des chutes forte puisque
health ouverture ça sonne et ska une
épaule et à la dernière chute qui est
fatal donc on va y venir et donc on me
refuse mais des barrières qui est le
propre de la sécurité en me disant que
elle risque de l'enjamber par une dame
de stage à la enjambé la barrière on je
demande à ce qu'on mette un matelas le
long du lit si jamais elle roule pour
qu'elle tombe sur matelas on refuse et
only de partir manu militari ont dit
vous partez le lan moi j'étais mortifié
maman pleurait ni me laisse pas me
laisse pas je pouvais rien faire d'autre
le lendemain matin j'arrive à 10 heures
sans prévenir et je vois ma mère dans le
couloir qui avait alors contre la
prescription médicale de l'hôpital
disait il ne faut absolument pas un
membre place et doit être en contentieux
sans envie sans bouger durant des
semaines voire un mois joie ma mère à
qui on avait mis un petit t-shirt
qu'avait le dujarrier qui était mal
repositionner et qui tenait avec sa main
sa petite canne
jules je fais un stand âge je vais
chercher incliné genou qu'est ce que
c'est que ça et là on me dit oh mais
votre maman a enlevé son attelle gimmi
c'est impossible puisque la tâche et
dans le dos hélas la main droite qu'elle
est droitier elle peut pas faire ça jc
un peu ce type c'est vous et puis jeudi
au pire si elle avait enlevé la tél si
je veux bien vous parlerais pas des
petits shorts et tee shirt et d'un
retrait donc on dit ah ben non on a dû
la lave et donc ça veut dire comme faute
un membres cassés on l'a mobilisés on ya
s'est enfilé un tee shirt
c'est dramatique et les souffrances a
vraiment rebondi après sur quelque chose
on va parler on va parler du quatrième
accident qui est malade et la talent va
en parler cet après midi voilà c'est
vraiment important alors là c'est à
l'usagé du temps mais je peux avec votre
accord les menaces que vous avez reçus
aujourd'hui par téléphone c'est ça voilà
donc aujourd'hui vous avez reçu des
menaces ou non en train d'être au
téléphone on téléphone à mon cabinet
dentaire son assistante qui décroche et
on lui dit vous dire madame schwarz sur
un ton très véhément monsieur numéro
inconnu qu'elle se taise et qu'elle
arrête de parler de tout ça et d'or pea
aujourd'hui jean pierre cazé incroyable
mon assistant dit mais vous êtes qui
monsieur qu'est ce que c'est il a
raccroché elle a intérêt de se taire et
il a raccroché donc là on voit vraiment
qu'orpea est prêt à tout si ça va on
avait parlé des 15 millions d'euros là
on parle de menaces d'intimidation
exactement de menaces d'intimidation
vous avez porté plainte alors j'avais
fait une main courante en décembre 2020
oui absolument me suis occupé de ma mère
et je souhaitais la maintenir en vie
mais je vais porter plainte alors là
c'est la quatrième qui est alors la
quatrième qui est dramatique donc maman
trois semaines après on m'appelle six
heures après sa chute pour me dire votre
moment il pas bien ah bon elle est
tombée auquel j'arrive et là je la
trouve gisante avec une tête moribonde
elle était en pratiquement à la limite
du coma elle respirait très mal elle
gémit sais j'en ai la chair de poule
rien qu'à dire ça en fin de compte il
avait elle était tombée dans l'après
midi il avait à 6 puis comme elle tenait
pas sur la chaise il avait mis au lit à
six heures du soir on prévient donc j'ai
dit bon ça suffit je prends l'ambulance
et on part aux urgences d'hôpitaux
américains parce que je savais qu là bas
une dame de 88 ans serait prise en
charge tout de suite et qu'elle
passerait pas la nuit dans le couloir et
à l'issue des radios et des irm fracture
de l'épaule pas consolidée fracture du
sternum fracture des côtes droites et
gauches fracture d dorso lombaire et un
énorme hématome gros comme un oeuf de
poule derrière la la tête donc elle
était pratiquement mourante allait
rester un mois hospitalisé avec des
soins très important elle est sans cesse
ils ont été au top et ensuite le 1er
août gfr j'avais la structure pour
l'avoir chez elle conclusion tout ça a
aggravé son alzheimer il ya eu un
syndrome de glissement hyper rapide et
elle ne marchait plus quelqu'un qui
marchait en rentrant cinq mois
auparavant ne marchait plus ne pouvait
pas se nourrir toute seule puisqu'elle
pouvait pas bouger le bras
elle a été volontaire à la lutte et elle
a fini sans pouvoir déglutir ni aliments
ni aux basques alzheimer lui avais se
perdent le contrôle adultes l'édition
voilà c est je pense je pense je me pose
la question si elle n'avait pas eu
toutes ces chutes toutes ces douleurs je
pense qu'elle aurait fêté ce 29 janvier
ses 90 ans non non nous étions isabelle
isabelle est ce que vous avez écrit de
savoir ce qui s'était passé parce que
j'avais là nous ça nous rend fous ici on
se dit tous ont envie de rien alors est
ce qu'on retient d explication aucune si
ce n'est elle est tombée aucune comment
qu'il mathieu mathieu s'il vous plaît à
dieu comment comment elle est tombée
c'est qui c'est quoi les explications
mais trois mois j'ai appelé la
directrice une première fois mais non
bonjour m salman et elle se met à rire
non mais attendez je suis en train de
vous appeler et vous me riez sonné je
vous parle de faits très graves mais oui
vous et écoutez vous me faites un
recommandé ok très bien enfin recommandé
pas de réponse ensuite je refais un
recommandé bon un peu plus musclée et
j'ai une réponse mais ça a changé de
direction dont l'huile est au courant de
rien je pars à 0 c'est vraiment c'est de
la poudre aux yeux
ces cinq ans et il vous manque de
respect et la madame schwarz elle va
voir sa mère régulièrement imaginer les
gens qui se disent mais j'habite à
l'étranger je mette 6000 euros par mois
pour mettre montée vers le luxe
exactement je vais donner le meilleur et
c'est ça le meilleur parce que quand
vous venez faire la visite à orpea on
dirait le ritz c'est joli il ya des
paillettes partout mais en fait ce
qu'ils font sexy manque de place mais
deux personnes j'ai un client qui me dit
mon père on mettait deux personnes dans
son lit a arrêté deux personnes dans son
lit j'arrive 6000 euros il a témoigné
d'ailleurs très récemment et aujourd'hui
aucun nom mais s'il faut il y avait deux
personnes dans le monde oui manque de
place à séoul on s'assied oui la chambre
la plus chère est à 12000 euros non
douze mille euros par mois sachant que
parfois et madame schwarz cela fait pour
pallier les manques certains envoient
leurs employés de maison en plus et
achète ce qu'il faut donc achètent des
couches achète de l'alimentation 6000
euros ils n'ont pas de quoi sortir une
biscotte mais il se moque de qui si je
peux me permettre à propos de couches
donc on leur met des couches qui montent
jusque sous la poitrine de façon à ce
que la couche et la contenance de toute
la journée
vous rentrez dans la chambre et se noie
dans leur école armand ella dire que les
rentrer ça déborde lorsque j'ai dit mais
pourquoi des couches alors n'avait pas
avant pourquoi des couches comme ça à la
limite la nuit ok pour paca s'est t on
dit mais quand on fait pipi ça monte
jusque dans le bas du dos tu dit alors
ah non non c'est pas un éléphant c'est
incroyable et est ce que vous avez
entendu parler de maltraitance sur
d'autres patients alors moi
personnellement je n'ai pas entendu
puisque tout est bien sectorisé parce
que les autres j'ai cru que ma mère
c'était un petit cas isolé mais j'étais
tout le monde a pensé ça envoie là je
découvre avec stupeur et froid qu'en fin
de compte c'est précisément et c'est
pour ça que j'ai tenu à témoigner je
suis j'ai voulu témoigner parce que je
considère que les personnes âgées on
doit en prendre soin des personnes âgées
ce sont nos exemples on est là grâce à
eux et de les maltraiter comme ça de
leur enlever toute identité toute
personnelle ou les dépersonnalise ça
devient des numéros on les prend pour
des imbéciles
les familles si vous les surveiller vos
proches vous êtes des emmerdeurs et on
vous payer 5000 euros donc vous avez
quand même le machine à cash bah oui et
alors donc vous avez reçu des menaces
qu'est-ce que vous avez pas
ça vous fait peur ces menaces que vous
avez reçue alors tout en joie qu'on voit
pas trop parce que vous êtes classé
aujourd'hui donc c'est vrai que c'est
faire peur mais moi j'ai pas peur parce
que je pense que je dis la vérité
je suis d'une famille mon père était un
grand résistant ma mère avait aussi son
tempérament elle était directrice
d'hôpital à l'ap-hp en plus vous êtes
donc elle a passé sa vie à s'occuper des
autres à faire en sorte que dans les
hôpitaux s'assoit confort n hésitez pas
à descendre s'il y avait un problème
c'est pour ça que je pense que quand tu
as une bonne direction on peut peut-être
pas liée à certains écarts ou à
certaines
aux deux factions aujourd'hui aussi pour
pour les autres qui sont la mort aussi
pour les en exactement moi pour moi ça
m'apporte rien maman est partie j'ai ma
souffrance j'ai ma douleur j'aime pas
mettre en avant mais les otages est vrai
qu'il faut faire via un réseau quand on
entend ça on se dit qu'il ya urgence
voilà je me dis qu'il ya urgence et pour
les autres ça et pour
que l'on respecte les personnes âgées -
chalon veut faire taire les familles des
victimes en gros le son c'est un truc de
fou faire des protocoles d'accord
transactionnel il ya des intimidations
incroyable il ya des protocoles d'accord
où on pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
familles qui ont accepté voilà de céder
en échange de bien sûr ils ont proposé
15 millions d'euros à viktor kassai
exactement delà ils peuvent proposer des
dizaines exactement aucune difficulté
hors pair leur problème c'est pas
l'argent c'est une machine à cash maison
quand même beaucoup d'argent
leur problème c'est leur réputation donc
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui va se passer
parce qu'on a envie de savoir même
juridiquement ce qui va se passer parce
que tout le monde a envie de se dire
aujourd'hui toutes les personnes qui
nous regardent et qui ont peut-être
leurs programmes par an leur maman ou
voilà où leur plus grande à air grand
mère dans des dents des doigts dedans
dès maintenant dans des sites orpea ils
se disent mais qu'est ce qui se passait
j'ai peur aujourd'hui peut-être qu'elle
la lumière est aussi korian la salle
naturalise exactement oui à mike et ce
n'est pas c'est une prise de conscience
parce que vous avez les gens qui avant
la sortie de ce livre se disait tout se
passe bien parce que si vous prévenez de
votre visite à priori tout se passe bien
mais là il se pose des questions et
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser ils
enlèvent leurs parents il s'est trouvé
d'autres solutions pour la plupart -
j'entends personnes qui me dit orpea
c'est formidable d'accord donc ce qu'il
a ce qui va se passer ces actions
collectives où chaque on va déposer
plainte le même jour pour que ça fasse
une masse un poids face à ce géant